there's a culture of abuse and
negligence in abortion facilities across
the country the goal of the regulations
is to protect women what these
regulations do is to try to impose such
financial burdens on clinics that they
are forced to close women have a
constitutional right to have an abortion
during the first trimester Virginia is
drawing new battle lines in the
decades-old war over abortion but unlike
most political battles over small
business regulations this debate finds
conservatives arguing for more
government control while liberals are
fighting for less new health care
regulations that were approved by the
Virginia Board of Health in April play
stricter regulations on clinics Senate
bill 924 classifies health clinics that
provide five or more first trimester
abortions a month as hospitals this
means they must abide by the same
standards as outpatient surgical centers
instead of only complying to the
standards for doctors offices which is
their current classification this is
really necessary in order to ensure that
women are being treated with care
consistent with our human dignity
mallory quickly is a spokeswoman for the
pro-life organization susan b anthony
List a group that supports the new bill
however women's rights advocates are
calling foul the bill includes building
regulations from the width of the
hallway to the size of the janitor's
closet things that would require
expensive structural renovations and
could potentially force the clinics out
of business the legislation is clearly
designed to do indirectly what they
cannot do directly so you cannot outlaw
abortion under the United States Supreme
Court precedent so what these
regulations do is try to impose such
financial burdens on clinics that they
are forced to close Larry Roberts is the
attorney leading the attack against the
bill he is representing Falls Church
health care center in Northern Virginia
who filed an administrative appeal
against the state claiming the
regulations are unnecessary and unfair
physicians that are practicing in
Virginia have been outspoken about the
lack of medical evidence that just
deciding these
sations we shouldn't discount the
importance of those building
requirements back in Philadelphia it was
actually a Virginia resident who died
when the emergency medical personnel
were unable to navigate the the hallways
as tragic as one death is is it enough
to warrant new and costly regulations
from 1974 to 2011 there have only been
three legal abortion related deaths in
Virginia with over 1 million abortions
performed the risk is minimal with less
than 1% of abortions involving major
complications Falls Church has had zero
deaths since its opening in 2002 the
mandated renovations would cost falls
church two million dollars a figure that
could put them out of business in no
other instance as the Board of Health
applied new regulations to existing
clinics or hospitals it's always been
for future facilities so abortion
facilities are being singled out as the
only ones where new regulations are
imposed on existing facilities that were
built properly under the former
regulations two out of 20 abortion
clinics in Virginia have already closed
citing financial burdens related to the
regulations that's a very serious sort
of foreshadowing of what could
potentially happen 28 other states have
passed similar bills placing strenuous
regulations on providers and so much of
government we hear people saying we need
to reduce regulations and lower the
burdens on businesses and help small
businesses grow all those principles are
thrown out the window when it comes to
abortion clinics any sort of law that
tries to restrict people being able to
use their best judgment to make
decisions about their bodies is like
counter to to justice in progress I
think in the state of Virginia
you